I recently spoke at the Financial Bloggers Conference in Chicago.
Almost every person you see here has a website offering money advice.
With literally hundreds of the nation's best bloggers all gathered in one place, I thought,...
..."What a great opportunity to catch up with a few..."
"...ask them for their single best savings tip."
Here's what they said.
My favorite frugal tip is to put an obstacle between you and your payment method.
So, some people will freeze their credit card in a block of ice.
But, if you have to stop and consider and go,...
..."Do I wanna melt that block of ice to buy this thing?"
No.
The single best savings tip is to cook your meals at home.
I cook my meals at home six to seven days a week.
I spent ten thousand dollars a year on my grocery bill last year.
If I would have eaten those meals out, two to three times more expensive, so you do the math.
For me, I actually stopped spending for like a month straight.
Like, I literally did not spend anything except for utilities or credit card.
Like, whatever my bills were, I did.
I didn't go into any stores. I didn't even go to Starbucks, which I love,...
...for one month to see if I can do it as a challenge.
Once I did it, I saved like, four hundred dollars and I realized,...
..."Okay, this is awesome because I didn't miss it."
So many things that people didn't have a hundred years ago.
I mean we all have heat inside of our houses.
We don't have to go out to an outhouse.
It's like things are pretty good now but, yet everybody wants to complain about how bad it is.
So I would just say, you know, accept what you have and just enjoy it.
And that really takes care of a lot of things.